and this one would jack off so much in
the bathroom his dad would get mad at it
but that told me i stopped jacking up i
pulled my i pulled my calf why is it a
special position i don't know because i
would go on my toes i'd do the michael
oh
extend your quad and do one of these
like it makes you bust faster i would do
that in the shower all the time i was
like 11 or some [ __ ] and one time my dad
he didn't even look me in the eye he
goes the water bill's high he goes nick
you got to stop masturbating so much and
i was like what no what are you talking
about and i ran in my room and i was
like oh god i was like mortified
did you jack off with no no do you like
material in the shower it was all up
here am i going to laugh
oh you got a good amount
hold on a second does every guy here
need material i need material yeah you
prefer material it's so easy
just use your imagination he's all like
time to jack off
he's like entering the matrix david's
like this
oh yeah baby give it to me right now
thumbs up i know through we're fighting
up new things right now